okay well for people who are joining
this livestream we are talking about
financial data feeds in Multan language
and obviously we have a bunch of
built-in capabilities in this area um
you know we can just go and say things
like I don't know I'd say MSFT price and
that will turn into Microsoft financial
entity lost price and we will get
15-minute delayed
data here um that's odd
why is it doing that why is it giving
that timestamp that wasn't it just
giving the price has this changed I
thought that but what does financial day
to do well financial data is still the
legacy form of just returning no
quantities no time series just reals
okay but this why is it doing it like
that why is it doing it I thought how do
you get just the price I mean why isn't
this an attribute for this thing to give
the the timestamp and the price I
thought the default was to just give the
price if you asked for the price before
in financial data you just get the price
okay but here
okay so if I say dated that comma all or
something then I should get a giant time
series right right um but then I really
thought that the without dated that it
will just give the result for most
things it does I would have to go back
through why and when this happened it
may have been something we needed to we
needed to add that in order to get
access to the timestamp within financial
data not going through entity value then
I claim it's wrong and maybe we need to
change the default property that we get
from the air from the NLU I'm making
sensor but you know the default thing
that it language um okay maybe I'm maybe
the problem is actually the NLU because
I think that this if I just do this and
I say um and I just say price there I'm
still getting that that's really odd I'm
sure that didn't do that okay any case
alright so what we're looking at here is
when you're not using built in financial
data from open language but you're using
for example a real-time feed that comes
from Bloomberg um what are we supporting
now it's the what what external feeds
are we supporting now there is Bloomberg
terminal Bloomberg data license and
Reuters good and Bloomberg terminal has
been updated to use library link okay
alright so let's take a look at how
those work now oh wow we got all kinds
of stuff here okay I see so this is
when you are connected to a Bloomberg
terminal that's what it looks like
that is the entity we're naming it the
type of entity is Bloomberg terminal and
the and that's Bloomberg's entity name
and Bloomberg's property name is that
correct yes okay and for Bloomberg data
license same deal cool it's very nice
okay that's pretty clean okay note these
aren't getting coming back in a list
with timestamps so we need to figure out
what's going on well no these shouldn't
be please don't have these come back
that way okay okay fine right well
that's easy because they don't yes I
think it's a problem over here I don't
think it's a problem I mean we should
return what go ahead
looking at this like financial data of a
stock and latest trade returns a
timestamp in a value and that may have
been what that the last in the entity
value framework was mimicking it would
nothing it won't it won't give you a
timestamp by default for something like
closed open high/low
okay well then I guess just a mistake
thing I think yeah you're right I mean
we can have something that gives this
pair but I mean last trade should give
that pair that's the right thing to give
for that for a lost trade but not for
price how do we know which does which I
mean there's hundreds of these this
really hundredfold they're documented
okay so we need to be consistent on this
fine well and you are being consistent
you're simply returning whatever the
thing that the external feed returns I
mean if px underscore lost so I mean the
question is whether we support any
linguistics around this or whether you
simply have to know that in Bloomberg
terminal P X underscore lost means you
know last price and I think what we're
doing initially is as I understand it is
to support linguistics and to just use
the actual tags that Bloomberg and
Reuters are using is that correct yes
correct
okay it's absolutely fine okay they say
they should return if they're returning
a pair which they may not have a way to
do then return a pair if they're
returning a single thing we've done a
single thing is a single element I'm
serious crazy yes we're not going to
return a single element time-series yeah
you know in the case we're now go ahead
can you ask in the burgh terminal or
data license examples can you ask for
the date for that value can you make the
same call but with no px last comma date
there if there is a field I don't know
if it but I'm sure there are fifty
thousand of them so I don't know there
might be there might be a whole separate
yes
so what that would look like is
something more like this comma whatever
right yes yeah okay okay which I think
it's just fine and now a question would
be in terms of the data type conversion
when it comes back in presumably if you
do ask for something which is a late the
importer will convert it into a wolf and
language data object correction data
screw yes okay there are some examples
of dates coming up okay actually there's
a question about date ranges okay okay
well let's take a look we'd like to use
span not take a look um so I'm going to
College eyes that I don't know about
dated so that's why date goes to no
that's wrong yeah okay so I'm but but
dated turns into something else right
underneath it turns into an attribute to
set up right Alan stated is just another
way of doing what you're doing here with
date goes to something as an attribute
earth of the property okay so one of the
things that dated does not currently
support to my knowledge is a step or is
that not the case does right so that
something dated could potentially add
yeah I think it's only told me a single
dates back interval right so we have
week or month or something right so I
say this know what we're saying
I think this requires some
discussion because I assume Nick is not
here the if we're gonna talk about dates
could somebody try to get Nick L please
could somebody please Steven I can look
for him okay I sure I just asked yeah
okay um okay so then the issue here is
that there's a lot of stuff to do with
date intervals and so on that's coming
and recurring dates and so on so the
question of what we do here
and I have to say this seems odd that
this is the only um you know I thought
we had a range specification in dated
which is effectively what you're asking
for here correct
now you know what we've had so far is a
list type thing um where you know where
its first date comma last date right or
interval or sometimes it uses interval
well what it should be using is date
interval okay but I think we've got
multiple different things we've got the
list we've got the the span we've got
date interval we've got interval all of
these things are sort of competing
things meaning was meaning these date
ranges okay my feeling is we probably
should support all of them but I think
we need to consistently you know we need
to move towards consistently turning
them into date intervals fine okay but
for your purposes here
I don't see a huge problem with this but
this could obviously be syntactically
made more elegant by being able to say
basically you know you'd end up saying
um this dated you know whatever it is
blah blah make sense
fine fine actually I'm sorry I didn't
mean that I meant dated hi comma blah
blah yeah but where would destroyed go
that would be a third argument or
there'd be a spanning dated or I don't
know yet that's what we want Nick for I
see fine okay that's fine okay data has
to enter interface with data interval I
don't exactly and also with recurring
dates okay they trained using interval
dandy okay so that's just you supporting
two different syntaxes for that yeah it
doesn't seem so elegant to use span you
know it spans seems more elegant
whatever we haven't figured it out yeah
fine you can support span you can
support interval fine
we've also got granularities and dates
so it's it's more complicated it's not
obvious what we show okay
okay tick data
okay so this is where it's returning a
structure of some kind yes and I don't
know where the size is coming from is
that what Bloomberg calls it or what yes
yes the number of traits
I believe but okay but I mean they call
it sighs yes yes okay so these are their
names sighs yes okay so notice that that
value I mean this is a complicated thing
because that value is presumably in
dollars yes and the size is presumably
in shares what okay so notice that in
fact we're sort of breaking our own
rules here because some things are
getting converted and some are not right
because we don't know the Bloomberg does
not give a way to provide what the unit
is so how are we in the case of price
how will we managing to I am curious
curating it by okay I think it's a
mistake okay I think what we should do
if we want to have something that is
called price here okay then curate it if
it is a raw thing here just return the
raw number they return because otherwise
we're not going to be consistent but I
do think that having if there is a
particular style of their properties
that's like this all uppercase thing if
we want to add some properties of our
own that maybe correspond to our own
financial data properties I think
they'll be really good it's very hard to
do that Jason gives gave an excellent
speech as to why that's because they're
very subtle it's very hard Jason here
can he speak for himself he's not we are
trying to reach him but he doesn't
answers
he's not here
okay the meaning of these I know it is
subtly different right but I would
recommend that I think it would make
sense to do a mapping but at least gets
the unit's right where you know yes we
will miss a lot of subtleties about
stock splits and this and that and the
other but I think it's worthwhile to add
some mapping of our limited number of
properties to their properties and just
document how we're mapping it just say
for Bloomberg terminal price means px
lost with units I am not comfortable
doing that because and that would mean
we are putting some of the data that is
sort of Bloomberg is a Bloomberg name
and I don't really put it don't want to
put it in my code the mapping wait a
minute this this is these are Bloomberg
names
oh yeah that's a separate issue I mean
is that that the the the point is what
you're doing is you're taking this
string and you're simply passing it to
the API is that correct correct yes okay
well so that's a separate issue which
probably have to ask somebody about
about putting you know if we say price
mapping that 2px lost I mean but but we
can't do we can't change the results
here okay it's just gonna cause trouble
make sense how many of these mappings
have you done you just you just know
what the unit is you get the unit from
the stock market don't you I look at
that if it is a price if it is a price
then I get the currency yeah that's it
that's all I what tells you that
surprised at the description but our
Santo so you have a table somewhere that
says given this query you'll go
to convert it to a price correct yes
okay so the point is that when you ask
Bloomberg first you ask for the list
that is a boat and they have a
description over there and if the
description says price in it then I wrap
currency around it does it that all
Saddam algorithm
you know curating it he's asking
Bloomberg what it is yes that's exactly
right I asked for discussion not the
same thing look okay we shouldn't
convert units fine unless we can do it
consistently unless you can consistently
convert the units in this case as well
can you I I mean I know this is taken
this as values sure I can do that but
the point but but do you it consistently
know for everything no I don't I know
the currency that is that of the
instrument and sometimes they are very
exact in their description sometimes
they have two or three sentences
describing something and that I cannot
know I think it's hopeless I don't think
you should try to do it I just that's my
um have raw numbers
um okay and this is all done with custom
entities energy stores and custom
entities yeah great
lovely so exactly the way I think it
should be I think this is very nice I
think it's great
um okay I'd like to see how the setup is
how could you also go further down there
is my stuff okay so I assume that our
various financial indicator charts will
correctly consume the stuff correct did
you understand my question I do I have
put a few questions out there for
example right right I don't know what on
earth this is there's something totally
weird but this is something where we
should be able to get this mm-hmm I mean
and that's why the outfit forms were
there because trading chart only takes
at list it does not take an association
well then that should be fixed I mean it
predated associations right you sure are
you sure that's still true because I
thought I thought they had been working
on that so that I could take thicker
consume things that came from visiting
value we want to switch financial data
over to return associations and
quantities of the things
who's working on trading chart do you
know okay whose whose p.m. you here is
it Andrea okay watching like that okay
but then would you try to figure out um
what let's see I mean so basically it
should be the case that whatever we get
from here is reasonably consumable by
these financial visualizations and so on
makes sense yes but that's the problem
for the visualization or do you want me
to change stuff I don't know I don't
know probably it's a problem in
visualization but okay so now this is
service submit so this is what is this
now
what what pay what where are you sending
me here just say yes right but you
probably have to that yeah I do okay
when did you last make a change to this
I wish him a few days ago so you should
have that okay
you
okay um do we want to get men who
apparently does work on training short
do we want to get them in this meeting
to ask these questions I mean
um okay so now what is this this is what
is the relationship between service
request and so is execute service
execute consumes requests requests are
basically why is there I carrot though
because it's still experimental I think
okay all right okay all right so it's
basically an inert form of all the
arguments who had passed a service
execute
the primary motivation so you can
package it up for our task yep well
it's a shame then that servers execute
is a two argument form here
because what you're proposing is a one
argument service request that I mean
this is reminiscent of URL requests
right it's unambiguous though you can
put a service trip well I understand
that but URL execute um the analog will
be URL execute right background noise by
the way that I'm okay
I see okay well fair enough that's the
same deal right that's a single HTTP
request which packages the URL and the
parameters yeah and other stuff maybe
okay all right
so service response is analogous to HTTP
response correct
um but service response is this mostly
from a restful api it's from anything
we've anything it might be no it's
unlikely to be from a restful api it's
from Bloomberg or Reuters API well this
is pubchem here oh sorry yes don't
they're going to be right they'll be
from whatever is provided by their I'm
sorry I don't understand that this is
the service request
what is this okay so the response here
is being given as an association with
service requests and results who wrote
this a service executive service request
here and so I read okay
so what determines the form of the
response they serve as a result is if
you would have just executed a service
execute in the old-fashioned way the
result is what you would have gotten
that value so all I'm doing over there
is just putting it in an association for
consistency no I'm sorry I don't
understand if you do URL execute right
yeah you get a HTTP response back okay
which contains things like the body
right yes okay so yes for your execute
that's true for your I'll read sorry
okay so URL execute of service acts of
service requirements re service execute
all the service request returns Walt
service response okay that's wrong
because again I think so
why isn't what URL execute returns does
not return an HTTP response that's
because your Alexa cute was there before
HTTP response you know the right
argument I think the correct argument
here is that I mean they're arguably
there should be a service read which is
the same deal as you know you are right
but let's look through more of these
okay that's my initial take is that you
know that service execute should return
the result am I making sense so um I
mean this is assuming that services I
mean services obviously aren't
necessarily HTTP based and they could
have any package you want in here and I
don't think this should be called
service request I think should be called
request form um it seems a little bit
annoying to have to have an extra
function their service read but I do
think service responses what I mean
service executes is what's gonna be
needed much more often and they just
want to get the result back and it's not
consistent to give back so usually this
is here for a task so yes I mean you
wouldn't want to use service requests
for normal things anyways yes it's
literally full service submit well you
think that but I don't think that's
necessarily true I mean has Christians
group looked at all this stuff they were
on the PR when I created it that's okay
but I mean you know they are developing
lots of new service connections and I
would have thought that any service
connection might want to use this
what
between so a service request is a
packaging and by the way it should it
should support things like the
authentication option
it's a packaging of what would otherwise
be naked leaf fed to a service executed
yes the authentication option gets messy
because you're also going to accept it
in the service metadata by the way
you're extremely loud Bob it's better
than being unhearable okay next question
is it true that any supported external
service can go asynchronous
it's like schedule tasks
um so I'm sorry so you said
any service execute could be done
asynchronously here I think there's a
major refactoring of the existing
service code that we need that would be
needed to be done to do it
so the answer is no if the answer no can
always return a task object that can be
queried ok let's take let's take a
random external service ok I want to I
want to pick a random external service
you
to be done well there's a bunch of stuff
that should be done before it's put into
a task object the authentication
whatever authentication steps need to
happen what 31st SeatGeek of something
okay
what are you telling me about how this
works so right now we got a service
connect and then we go to service
execute can you open up connecting an
authentication
okay so yeah I mean I don't know if it
pops open dialogue so we try to
authenticate it I assume it does so
ideally what we would want to happen is
if you wanted to do service submit of a
request to SeatGeek
and you didn't have an authenticated
connection it would generate one before
it does any sort of callback or
asynchronous action one thing that it
only works that the service submit only
works if you have already authenticated
I mean I have to ask Christian about
what's been implemented but it would be
easy to implement it for everything
assuming you're already authenticated
fine and so long as it errors correctly
if you do a service submit and you have
not authenticated that service it has to
error out in the correct way right yes
to do it to like separate out pre
requests from the post request and put
the post request into a callback
function is this refactoring that would
make it all done very well that's what I
think for him is done for these
financial services okay and I think
they're I think we could we could take
requests into them one by one or the
ones that we think it's worth really
kidding we should do I mean I I think
it's either gonna be a bulk things don't
work our while to do this for everything
because most of these things are not a
sinker are not interestingly
asynchronous they making sense latency
you want to hide right right I'm
thinking slow things that people use a
lot we could I don't think we should I
think it should be once and for all that
we do this we shouldn't have to do it
for every individual thing
alright let's let some address I think
we have Bret and min here so let's just
talk about trading chart for a second
okay
so the question is whether trading chart
now supports I mean this looks very very
primitive what's here
like for example trading chart how would
we okay so the Bloomberg link is
returning things like this open high/low
close association does does the
financial indicator visualization stuff
support that or not i mean it don't
remember off the top of my head if it
does but i mean there's certainly date
information that would be missing that's
missing from that i agree i agree so a
question is should it support i i don't
know how would i mean if if i think that
this is kind of a fake version because
this is i don't even know what that's
not fake it that's not fake I'm just
taking the values okay fine so you've
got a time series okay terrific
so if I take that time series okay so
all is good so if I take that time
series and I say date let's plot on that
time series right that's probably going
to fail horribly ah well I mean because
I mean you have a time in the new hairs
okay so does that's obviously not the
way it should be because this time
series has in it if I say that time
series and I say take three elements of
the time series what's it gonna do I
don't even know what an earth that did
what did that know okay so that's wrong
as well so can we make sure this gets
reported to the folks who are working on
time series that's supposed to do
anything well I think it's supposed to
get the first three elements
time-series is atomic you scroll down a
little bit although it's not doing the
other thing either I don't think sorry
go ahead
what I'm just so those are probably
absolute times there which looks pretty
those are absolute times yeah the
back-testing development how is that
going and the time series modernization
what about time series modernization I'm
rid of all the temple data nonsense and
having time series work properly
I don't think I know anything
about that okay would it be in your
group or not time-series no that's
Scotia and okay fine fine no problem
okay so alright so if you have that time
series out of curiosity what happens
with trading chart now let's try and
find out okay yeah it probably doesn't
like this is my basic bottom line here
is we've got to get all these
connections to actually work together
okay
so right I mean I don't think there's
anything so dateless plot needs to work
with these things with associations and
trading chart needs to do that too
okay right I mean I think the question
is yeah so you have I mean in some way
this data is equivalent to giving Lisp
lot something like x1 comma a 1 B 1 C 1
X 2 yeah
and so I I think Roger has you know a
whole you know plan for vector sorts of
things fine
well Andreas should pull together
whoever's be having this should pull
together what's gonna happen because the
basic bottom line has got to work so how
it works we can discuss make sense I
think that's fine and as long as we're
standardized on you know the strings
open high low close volume as such then
for trading job I would think so yeah
there is number of events also but I am
well I mean for our purposes I don't
think it really matters if there's
additional elements in the Association
you know but I'd like to have the keys
you know standardized in the you know
that it we aren't getting open in some
places and oh and others and right does
that make sense yeah yeah I mean you
might want to support multiple things um
possibly but okay so all right I think
that's everything we needed for the
visualization folk um thank you very
much okay thank you okay so
I assume we're not displaying anything
here that we shouldn't be now now this
is very VPN Basin nothing is going to
okay um the okay so I'm also proposing a
new option connection settings for
service connect which is currently not
that do we have an analog of that
anywhere else we have one for URL read I
believe now what was it but um that does
the speed manipulation if you want those
or high-speed sorry so that again URL
what URL read separates connection
settings so
there's documentation for your
connection settings well I in the
connection settings page
but wait while it listed on the URL read
if it's that's because we haven't had
okay you're saying there's new
documentation for connection settings
yes you are proposing that connection
settings be added also to URL read yes
service connect no no to URL read are
you suggesting that connection settings
is added to URL read I think it's
already in 12 oh yes okay oh right so
this is the max download speed max
upload speed terrific yeah great I don't
see a problem with this I mean that's
we'll need to do a quick document 8 this
documentation looks reasonable - we'll
need to do a quick documentation session
to go over this and put in it see also
and all those kinds of things make sense
like like this should point to ping time
it should point to what what's the
timeout how do we characterize the
timeout here um time constraint right
I'm making sense what else should this
point to time what else sighs point to
just dot act I think it should point to
authentication also I mean there's
several other things here verifies
security certificates all these various
other things right yeah these connection
settings interact with the Preferences
dialog internet proxy settings etc it's
not saturated proxy settings is not
supported it's just documented is it in
the plan - or howhow would these things
relate them if they were supported I
mean you know I'm talking about right
there's a dialog and the Preferences
dialog where you can set your yes yes I
think it would by Paulist on
and that's why proxy setting this has
not been touched because of that because
it's rather complicated override you're
saying yes okay that's a separate
discussion okay but here right I have no
problem with connection settings be part
in being part of service connector and
you should tell Christian that also
because he may be able to use it for
some other things okay makes sense this
should already be an easy way to
implement that based on saying default
values for connections
okay so service submit all right so
submitting a a a request service name
why isn't that just called service we
debated that maybe service is better I
think it is better because I think it is
our name for that service it is the
thing which would be the first argument
of service service execute were you two
also is connect where you to just use
that does it accept that you are
uniformed service requests
we're the first argument is Reuters
sodoes it does that there are examples
about it too I believe okay
basically you can take away so this
execute and placing service request and
that should be fine no no I understand
but so I think the correct thing here is
for call the service and call the next
thing request okay and then and then it
should take except a service object okay
perfect
as the service okay which is why it
shouldn't be called service name okay
okay
handler functions okay so what are the
handlers for for example the Reuters
service response received its where to
Bloomberg it is more interesting but
with writers is just response received I
can show you there okay alright okay
continuous task is not ready yet is it
well it is documented implemented oh I
didn't know that is continuous tasks
generally implemented not generally it
is for Bloomberg okay so what is the
status of getting continuous tasks
generally implemented it works with
session subnet or something did you do
you mean with service submit okay so
wait a minute is this right or is this
wrong cloud submit of continuous tasks
and what if what does this mean what
does continuous
do with the different forms of
submission from my perspective it's a
continuous as a subscription is just a
wrapper
it's a note well okay I'm asking you the
question I'm asking Tom or anybody else
the question if I set up a continuous
task like watch this camera feed and
send email if you see a gazelle jump
through the picture right right which
forms of submission work with that
well you can I'm not sure you're asking
what can you put continuous tasks inside
of you can put continuous tasks inside
clouds submit does it work I think so
yes
okay what about session submit local and
local submit I I don't know okay so
let's that's what we need to find out
yeah okay so let's please find that out
well I think the answer is for certainly
food doesn't matter it doesn't matter
let's not do that here let's find that
out let's figure out what this should
happen and let's bring this to the core
software engineering meeting okay Andrea
can you get that to happen please yes
okay all right so now but meanwhile
service submit you are proposing that
there be a
wrapper continuous tasks around a
service request that causes the handler
functions to be continuously recalled
every time there is data available
correct
is that an abuse of continuous
tasks I think it is that's not what
continuous tasks means right fine so it
could be triggered tasks but a triggered
task doesn't exist yet does it no it
doesn't right but but trigger tasks we
just had a conversation about triggered
tasks and who here remembers what the
design well how the trigger works in a
triggered task one trigger is file
updated in the cloud right the trigger
is not special to the I'm well aware
that this is a different trigger right
so I'm saying that's why I'm asking
about what the design of triggered task
is right because normally what triggered
task would be is what's the trigger what
should be done am I making sense
mm-hmm so here in a sense this is the
wrong design because the correct design
would be asked for the trigger which is
part of the service request and the what
should be done is simply this result
received thing I'm making sense but this
is service submit so you said I I'm
aware I'm aware so I'm saying that the
right thing to do would be a service
submit of a triggered task of the
trigger and then this you don't need to
give a handler function right
just doing a submit just like you could
say cloud submit of scheduled tasks and
we'll go off and do the scheduled task
right it doesn't have to have a handler
last time we talked about this we said
it was service submit was what we should
be using we can you know each one of
these cycles takes months of you know
excuses aside okay we're just you know
let's just figure out I don't think this
is quite right but it doesn't matter
because the fact is you know this
functionality you know we should get
some version of this functionality even
considered experimental and we will
change the detailed way that it works
later okay I think it's wrong and I
think the correct way to do it is with a
triggered task of the trigger and then
the payload you know action okay but I
think that it will be good to have other
examples of submit Abul services and I
guess you can use continuous tasks now
for this thank you okay thank you I know
I know and this is a good good you know
yes what
yeah that's has taken use we every time
we get a meeting with it there's like a
complete design change and then nothing
gets done so at this time I just you
know okay fine yeah we were simply
talking about what we want to talk about
dated for a minute and the use of
intervals in dated but but that's okay
so I mean I guess I'm fine with the
service about mechanism for now what's
this this is a scheduled tasks this
really does make sense this one is okay
yeah okay and then what's happening is
you're decoding this for the Bloomberg
data license service yes they have a
schedule
they operate and then they have a call
back to us you you poll you you I mean
okay okay so we're calling in some way
we're polling
I mean the granularity is massively long
it's like daily or weekly no I
understand but you have to have this
process up and running while that
happens no there is a way to retrieve
whatever it's a task you have deployed
yeah and then you can what does that
mean I mean that's that's a way to do
that on our side or on their side on
their side they have API calls that you
can query okay so my question is this
I do the service submit I want to get a
daily I mean let's say that the response
received says send email send mail right
yeah okay so then my I quit my Wolfram
one you know I quit my Wolfram language
session yes okay now what happens it's
you'll have to restart this task yeah
okay so wait a minute the task dies if
the parent Wolfram language session you
know you reconnect to it you reconnected
you can reconnect yes hold on hold on
hold on did you hear what I said look I
said the action is send mail okay so the
question is what's running that and
you're saying unless I have my local
colonel running this simply isn't gonna
work yes that's true
okay what about on the cloud what about
if I cloud submit this well it has to be
service submit not cloud submit I
understand but what if what if this was
maintained not locally but in the cloud
well if you did cloud submits that
probably can't work for these particular
services because they basically you're
connecting through them through VPN and
so on which we couldn't support from the
cloud it could in principle it could in
a private cloud well okay so so in a
private cloud could you fire and forget
your desktop session so to
big I think you could I think in prints
that would work I'll get it to them what
does this become this becomes a cloud
submit of a scheduled task of a service
request no it becomes a cloud submit of
a I don't know some sort of task of a
service submit I think well if it's a
card it would just be a cloud execute of
a service submit a cloud evaluate of a
service submit that that might be what
you're saying yes sorry you're probably
right
yes okay so in other words all that's
happening is the service submit is
running on a kernel in the cloud and
submitting to the cloud infrastructure
thing that's right okay that makes sense
to me all right
okay so are there any more issues here
it seems like we've we've addressed
these issues the only thing that is a
change here is that a service executes
of a service request should return the
payload and we should have a service
read yes okay and and there's going to
be a documentation session that we need
to just finish off those those functions
right okay now a quick thing for um for
Nick the main issue is how we represent
in dated how we represent both arranged
in dated which apparently data doesn't
support which I find really bizarre both
a range and a-growlin arity to the range
for dated making sense yeah I mean the
so the initial version of data it only
supports a either specific year a
specific date or all to represent yeah
yeah I mean we had looked at having you
know we have the the prototype version
but we're still the the design for date
interval
as a general construct in the language
being extended to dated was always sort
of the plan where we could say you know
we have our start date our end date and
then a step size associated with life
well maybe as a cheap version of that
for right now we could have you know the
same thing that we have in like air
temperature and god knows what else we
just have a start comer and commerce tap
right yeah correct yeah I think we
should do that I think we should add
that to dated okay okay should be rather
straightforward because I think it will
flow directly into the date option and
that would then solve your problem for
him of having a reasonable syntax okay
for slicing the time series yeah Allen
do you have any concerns with that since
this plugs into the entity value backend
and I know Tony's not here but I just
thought I'd check yeah I don't I don't
have any immediate objection to it I'd
have to know some other data etcetera
already support this just night dated
framework so I'm good let's do it now
these guys also want to put a louse pan
as a syntax and I think we should do
that yeah we've talked about having
something like date span as the the
general notion of those and potentially
tying it in to span the main concern is
that spans sort of a structural
reference at this okay maybe we don't
want to support that the other one is to
support interval mm-hmm yeah I think
those could all easily bound into the
same thing and we do have the notion of
interval of two dates as a qualifier in
some places okay fine
so let's I'm lyin plot it works - okay
so can we go for this and try and get
this in quickly yeah I'll check with
Tony right after this and make sure
there's not gonna be any hiccups on the
back end but it should be easy to
support and dated as long as the bat the
server understands it by a step that's
that's more granular than the data we
have available or we interpolating
values or what
what are we doing when we do I have
think what we should do that's a good
question I think there's a future answer
and a current answer I think the current
one we just returned the best
granularity we have am I making sense I
think the notion of a jerk oh yeah kids
will be getting it will be getting a
time periods out so everything will be
yeah actually that's right it's time so
what the heck right the only point in
the time series is is proving the time
series to downsample it right and I
think the protocol should be I mean
don't we have a standard way of down
sampling assigned time series for a
particular granularity I thought there
was a standard way to do that
resample time series sample something
like that
um so that's what we should use for this
okay
super quickly let's get a demo from
Fahim of the actual live system with
Bloomberg okay um can we start merging
this Stephon and then have a
documentation session yes great to play
a card for my livestream temple plotting
okay these are good suggestions comments
from our livestream here let me post
them that would be nice do we support
that good idea that this is a Brett
thing okay good
Adair could you feed this to Brett
please yes um it spans
cameras are plotting intervals
understand what that means two people
here understand what that means
well let's Plus this to Brett and that
this is something maybe it can be in an
ILD meeting to talk about dates pans and
plotting okay Andrea can you get that
okay okay all right
let us continue um okay Fahim you were
gonna do a demo show you a quick demo
can you share please oh dude I do share
please yes yes how I'm trying okay wait
by the way does this only work on the
windows the Bloomberg terminal yes a lot
to the top again please yes okay shall I
get today
examples please the ones who can
today because it's hooked up to entity
properties we have all the decorations
what does that mean what does that mean
sorry you mean you mean so wait a minute
so if you say lengths of entity
properties a Bloomberg terminal oh you
did that 50,000 things it's actually
more that's crazy
could you just do random sample of that
comma 10 for example
well they're gonna collect
sponsors health edu Pro Prague women oh
yeah they have for how many women are in
a company
what is the Twitter sentiment there's a
pop you know interesting
they really expanded this um okay
and this is an example of Nintendo
company yeah what's special about that
it's um I mean it's a numbered I think
by the way in these examples you should
show some of these should show off some
of the Bloomberg cool feature IDEs oh
it's coming down and this is a quantity
well it won't be a quantity array in the
future because we're not gonna have
those quantities I'm gonna have it yes
and this is I mean it's sad but it's the
way I think it has to be right now
sending pending these rapper properties
which we may choose to add okay this is
an example of thought and yep this is a
do you look up for IBM this is going to
change as we discussed yeah that will
not not need to there will be no need of
that yeah that is it'll just say data
set of service execute which is the
right thing right and here's an example
of querying all the field list so it's a
cute example so you'll see the dynamic
Oh feels changing what does that feel
what is the fields list what do you mean
by fifty thousand that you just saw
entity properties yes we are collecting
them okay so this is asynchronous so I
can I don't have to do it locking you
see so for long sort of cool yeah it's
very cool and this is market bar
subscription so this is what we
discussed about the triggered task will
someday take over this what is this this
is market power subscription save I am I
don't know what that means what is
market ball it's open high low close Oh
for every minute okay and that's
that's cool yeah this is because we set
it and continuous tasks and whenever
market borrow update event or market
door into the land and start happens we
collect that data good it is good I mean
whether this can be more packaged I
don't know because I mean not having to
design define the explicit event you
know handlers would be nice very
impressive it's very wonderful I can see
that it's very nice it's it's some a lot
of very useful stuff and this is we are
streaming data from Bloomberg and I can
put it dynamic around this this is
market power so by the way several
things first of all I assume we're going
to have a bunch of workflow
documentation about this is that correct
well there though so I have written a
huge guide paid for it but sure tutorial
this is something we need to meet with
Brian to go through yes I think you're
gonna need to be workflow so I think
it's gonna need to be a video about this
um well Stephen what we want to do is
get this stub functions documented
finance platform will follow on after
you see okay fine place version 12 yep
that's what we're doing so that's great
alright and that's it that's I mean I
know it was wonderful okay they have a
question from our live stream a lot of
professional financial data sources are
there plans to include other publicly
available data and move now for more
from language
we have gazillions of PS later yes but
but I think the question must be a
little different because I think the
person asking it must know already know
that so it's asking about not Bloomberg
Reuters X ignite or Yahoo I'm not sure
what I mean we also have data from
Morningstar and some other sources um
but I'm not quite sure what once what's
being talked about there I mean there's
direct data from the SEC years all kinds
of stuff I'm not sure what's being asked
there um okay this is great
um okay anything else we need to cover
in this meeting right just final
decision so we're gonna merge this stuff
into version 12 and we'll set up a
documentation session to review the
pages that's fine
now so I understand people who just get
a generic Wolfram 1 for example are not
in a position to use this is that
correct that's correct
right so it's it's really it's so how
are we indicating that in the
documentation I mean it's a warfarin
finance platform feature to have the
actual active drivers for things like
Bloomberg and Reuters and you also have
a Bloomberg and Reuters license mm-hmm
so is how is that being we need a scheme
for indicating that on the documentation
well we had one in the past so we could
use the one we hadn't used in the past
which was what well in the past the
documentation was just absent so that's
that's called the scheme which is an
anon scheme right we that's not the
scheme we're going to use that's the if
we designed a scheme yes can it's it's
just like many other things where you
know like raspberry pie functionality
only obviously only works if you have a
raspberry pie um it makes a bit more
sense now could we have more data feeds
and we have data feeds that apply to all
platforms which we did not have before
what do you mean well previa
it was only when we only had Bloomberg
terminal and that was only on Windows
and it wasn't really integrated with the
entity framework yeah I understand but
now it is not so now we have we have
Bloomberg terminal is still only windows
but the Reuters and Bloomberg data
license works on they work they work on
all you know all people are really gonna
like this this is really very nice yeah
yeah um the Bloomberg people should like
it too as and you know this is a good is
really a good thing um okay
outstanding all right let's get it
finished through the documentation we
need an indication in the documentation
which will work out when we do the
detailed documentation review fantastic
thank you okay and for folks on the
livestream thanks for joining us and we
are actually about to roll into another
livestream about a different topic so
hope to see you there okay everybody